it's february 1st 2022 and you're
watching the code report news for people
who code and stuff everybody loves
billionaires but for some of us that
love can go too far recent polling data
indicates that elon musk is the world's
most popular billionaire by a wide
margin but he's been having a rough week
not only did he lose billions of dollars
in net worth but a college student named
jack sweeney from the university of
central florida created a twitter bot
that tracks the location of his private
jet elon fearing for his safety slid
into the 19 year old's dms the world's
richest person offered him five million
dollars or no i'm sorry five thousand
dollars to take it down most teenagers
would be if elon asked them to but
apparently this kid is some kind of
alpha giga chad and counter offered with
50k and an internship but elon declined
what an
idiot and now you're hearing about it on
my channel because the streisand effect
is in full swing the story got picked up
by the mainstream media and the elon jet
twitter account has grown by over a
hundred thousand followers over the last
couple days some people call this guy a
stalker or extortionist especially
because elon only has one private jet
unlike most billionaires like jeff bezos
recently went to the cop 26 climate
summit in his private jet to lecture us
about how we're destroying the
environment but he has multiple private
chats making it much harder for stalkers
to track him bezos also has a 500
million dollar mega yacht while elon
doesn't have a yacht at all so elon kind
of did this to himself by only having
one mode of transportation i realize
he's saving up his money to go live on
mars but now everybody in the world
knows how to track november 6-8 tango
sierra but how does a 19 year old figure
out how to track a private jet is jack
sweeney some kind of coding genius well
the code is on github so i did some
investigating it's written in python and
uses the open sky network api to track
the unique transponder of the plane this
is a really cool api because it's free
and made possible by a huge network of
people who relay data to the system from
all over the world flight tracking is
perfectly legal and there's all kinds of
different apps that rely on this data in
the code he tracks the plane's altitude
and position every few minutes then
there's an algorithm that will look for
changes from the previous position to
determine a takeoff or landing event in
most cases the plane is just on the
ground but when a takeoff or landing
event occurs it uses the google maps
static api or takes a screenshot with a
browser to generate an image of the
plane's current location it then uses
both the twitter and discord apis to
post that content on social media it's a
pretty clever way to take public data
and turn it into interesting content on
social media if you want to see a full
twitter bot tutorial on this channel let
me know in the comments this has been
the code report thanks for watching and
i will see you in the next one